的问题，
跟我本人有关系，
但是不完全是我本人的事情，
我妈妈在呃21年3月份的时候去世了，
然后呢，
她去世的时候，
现在我跟我爸爸嗯现在住的这个房子呢，
还有房贷没有还完，
然后呢，
嗯呃房贷一共是都是贷了115万，
然后呃装修的贷了40万，
妈妈去世的时候，
呃房贷连那个装修的钱还有104万左右没有还，
当时妈妈去世之后呃留下了一笔就是股份是在他公司的，
大概提现之后有40万，
然后当时妈妈去世之后收的礼金有30万左右这样子，
然后呢，
妈妈去世了之后，
我有一段时间就是生病了，
就是心情上那种，
然后住院了，
然后呃当时我的呃意识不是很清楚，
然后是爸爸嗯送我去的，
呃，
听我爸爸说，
我当时住院是花了大概有六七万左右的钱，
然后这个房贷的月供，
呃不是很便宜，
因为我们家面积有点大，
有200平左右，
然后呢，
月供的话比较贵，
一个月要呃6000左右的月供，
然后但是我爸爸他不是，
他的工资比较低，
我们家主要是靠我妈妈，
就是呃，
我上小学之后是主要靠妈妈挣钱，
爸爸之前是做生意的，
但是嗯，
我上小学之后，
爸爸生意就那个，
呃算是破产了吧，
就是之前是有工资，
但是。
破产了，
然后呢，
就是靠我妈妈挣钱，
嗯，
因为这个房子月供特别的贵，
我爸爸他有点负担不起，
所以他就是请求我的爷爷帮助嘛，
是我爷爷之前是每个月给我们呃4000左右帮我们还房贷，
然后我爸爸的工资再出2000这样子，
但是因为爷爷年纪也大了，
他自己也要看病什么的，
然后就可能没有这么多钱，
慢慢的就是负担不起这个月供了，
然后我爸爸当时就是借了钱，
呃，
就是今年的时候，
去年9月份的时候，
爸爸其实当时就没有钱了，
因为呃妈妈留下来的那个礼金加上股份的话，
呃，
还这个房贷是不够的嘛，
而且还要维持我们的日常，
我还物业费什么之类的，
然后呢，
爸爸就负担不起了，
他当时就没有钱了，
他的信用卡也欠了一部分钱，
然后呢，
身上没有现金了，
平时是一个很好的人，
但是他没钱了，
他就不知道该怎么办了，
然后当时爷爷奶奶呢也在家里，
我也在家里，
爸爸当时就回家把呃信用卡跟那个他储蓄卡放在桌子上，
然后给我们留了一张纸条，
说他没钱了，
接下来的房贷，
包括这5万块钱的信用卡的钱，
要我跟我爷爷奶奶去想办法还，
爷爷奶奶当时帮他还了这个信用卡的钱，
但是接下来我他呃找了一个女朋友，
就是找了个阿姨，
这个阿姨非常好，
因为爸爸没有钱了，
这个阿姨借了30万用她自己的。
房子贷款贷了30万给爸爸还钱什么的嘛，
反正就是现在爸爸就是觉得这个月供还是太贵了，
阿姨贷款贷了钱，
把这套房子的房贷全部还完了之后，
想把这套房子转到我的名下，
因为这套房子是妈妈的名字，
然后这个的话需要外婆签字，
我外公去世了，
需要外婆签字，
然后嗯，
外婆的话就是其是今年九月份的时候就在说这个事儿了，
当时外婆就不是很同意，
她意思是说，
呃，
阿姨跟我爸爸年纪很不是50多岁了，
不是那种很年轻的阿姨，
他们也是，
就是嗯，
相伴的过日子嘛，
他不打算生小孩儿，
当时我外婆就说我爸爸是不是找女朋友了，
然后问我说这个阿姨的年纪有多大，
他们准不准备生啊，
因为我们家就我一个小孩是女儿嘛，
然后我外婆就跟我说，
如果他们以后给你生了弟弟，
你在这个家里的地位就是就不像现在过得这么的呃，
舒畅了，
他们也不会管你的，
就这种，
然后我就跟我外婆说，
我说这个阿姨她年纪也很大了，
自己也有小耗婆就是不同意，
当时我以为是因为我外我不放心我爸爸，
然后我我当时也不太放心我爸爸，
但是后来就是我生病什么的都是爸爸带我去看病，
然后开药什么的也是爸爸付钱，
就是我的一切都是爸爸负责哦，
然后到了今年年底的时候，
阿姨借给爸爸的钱也是花完了，
然后呢，
呃，
爸爸就说一定要把这个房子转到我这里了，
不然到时候如果要强制执行的。
这个房子可能会被法院拿走，
年轻的时候我爸爸去外婆家找外婆说了这个事情，
但是外婆还是一直不同意，
然后我就有点呃，
不太懂，
就是为什么这样子，
然后我现在也有点看不清了，
你外婆之所以不同意，
是因为他不信任你的爸爸，
你的爸爸从他的行为模式上来说，
他可以在家里留一张纸条，
说这事儿我不管了啊，
你们去管吧，
他是一个让人会不太信任的一个角色，
所以你的外婆是不信任你的爸爸，
所以不愿意去签这个字，
只要你外婆不签这个字，
这个房产你爸爸就没有办法做任何的处分，
对不对？
嗯，
爸爸现在的意思是想把这个房子过户到你的名下是吗？
对，
那你有去了解过，
这个房子现在还在欠着贷款的情况下，
怎么能过户到你的下吗？
他已经把这个单子还清了，
我也不知道这个阿姨真的有这么好了，
但是确实是这样，
就是因为阿姨家里比较有钱，
她的，
呃，
老公也说就实啊，
我小姐妹啊，
龙飞姐，
我不是说你爸爸一定是坏人，
但是请你听完龙飞姐的分析啊，
如果这个房子你外婆同意了过户到你的名下了，
假设有一天，
那你是精神上是需要去治疗的，
需要去吃药的，
对不对？
嗯，
你是非常依赖你的爸爸的，
对不对？
之前比较依赖，
但是在还好。
了，
因为我现在有工作了，
就是，
而且这工作是那个阿姨帮我找的，
阿姨对我跟爸爸确实挺好的，
我告诉你的是外婆担心的点好不好？
我担心的点是假设外婆签了这个字，
这个房子就不受外婆任何的控制，
就算这个房子在你的名下，
外婆也拿不准，
你将来有没有可能被你的父亲精神控制，
失去这套房子，
将来有没有可能被你的父亲情感绑架，
用这套房子去抵押，
去贷款，
去欠债，
这是你外婆担心的点，
明白了吗？
嗯，
但是他不签的话，
这个钱确实是阿姨借给爸爸的，
到时候爸爸不还阿姨钱的话，
他们两个之间的关系也也会破裂，
而且阿姨也帮了我们很多啊，
如果这个房子过户到你名下了，
请问你们拿什么钱来还阿姨的债？
是这样的，
因为爷爷的话，
当时是爷爷开场，
然后给我爸爸做，
然后呢，
当时爸爸赔了之后把设备都卖了，
然后爷爷还有厂房，
大概就是在乡下的，
是那个就是工业用地嘛，
然后当时村里是说要是征收走，
但是具体什么时候征收的话，
可能要呃两三年这样左右，
然后征收走了之后呢，
200个或者呃左右嘛，
然后我我爷爷的意思是分50个给我的姑姑，
然后150给我爸爸，
然后我爸爸拿这个钱来还这件事情。
跟是否要过户房产给你有什么关联呢？
对的，
有一个重要的点我没有说清楚，
就是因为呃，
阿姨那边的钱急着还，
所以爸爸要把这个过户到我这里，
然后用这个房子去再去还，
帮阿姨还这个钱，
他问题不就出来了吗？
那奶不放心，
奶奶的担心不就在这儿吗？
一旦房产过户到你的名下，
用这个房产去贷款的话，
你就是主贷人，
但你是欠银行的钱的，
那个人明白了吗？
这是我觉得缓一缓你外婆的顾虑是有道理的啊，
就没有，
我知道爸爸对你很好，
爸爸又带着你去治病啊，
就这那的啊。
但是坦率的说，
你的这个爸爸并不靠谱，
她不靠谱的点在于什么呢？
你有没有发现他一直在靠女人，
他一直直在吃女人，
爸要么就是靠你的妈妈，
要么就是靠现在这个阿姨，
那他们以后还得靠你，
她可不是很靠谱啊，
她做了一件事情，
就是让我非常的，
因为我这个生病住院的话，
她就是不想让我被，
就是登记上说哎呦这方面的那个生病的这个就是她说她自己也生这个病，
然后他讲你叫我来，
就是每天每个月供我是这样子，
然后我就是感觉我爸爸这方面做的让我太那个了，
就想告诉你啊，
你爸爸爱你或许是爱你，
但你爸爸。
本身是一个不靠谱的人，
你不要什么事情都相信他，
不要什么事情都依赖他，
你要学会自己保护自己，
如果这件事情外婆始终不同意签字的话，
那你要看看外婆是对你有几分爱，
因为外婆可能还有别的子女呢，
比如说举个例子啊，
假设这个房子值1000万，
我们假设外婆能分到，
比如说举个例子啊，
没有去细看，
假设外婆能分到100万，
外婆这100万她是想给谁就能给谁的，
你其实我觉得要靠谱的做法，
你就问问外婆的真实的这个想法，
外婆是想给谁，
那如果外婆想给你的话，
你要让外婆提前要写一个遗嘱，
写明白外婆的从你妈妈那里继承的这个钱将来应该由谁来继承，
从你妈妈这里继承的份额，
将来应该由谁来继承啊，
再见啊，
拜拜，
嗯，
爸爸对女儿的这份爱，
这份关心，
为女儿去考虑，
我觉得这个东西还是嗯大家对吧，
还是不否认的，
但从这个故事总体的走向来看的话，
他爸爸真的这辈子就是在吃女人是吧？
妈妈在世的时候是妈妈挣钱，
那妈妈去世的时候，
他又找了个阿姨。
提，
然后阿姨还给他借那么多钱，
他这一辈子就是靠女人啊，
也不明白这样的男人到底哪里有魅力了，
这么多女人上杆子要跟他，
他是属于那种当自己没有办法还房贷了，
自己可以留一张字条在家里面，
让他的女儿和他的对吧，
女儿的爷爷奶奶一起去解决困难的人，
他自己就走了。
是这样的人他是靠不住的，
你们记住啊，
这样的男人他注定是靠不住的啊。